for more on all of this we are joined by
Leslie Sanchez a CBS News political
contributor and Republican strategist
Leslie good morning morning
the president's criticism of Mitch
McConnell I mean why is move doesn't
that just sort of pull the party apart
by doing that absolutely right and the
interesting part about it while Mitch
McConnell may not be the most popular
person on Capitol Hill it has done one
thing it's built Allegiance around him
and for his colleagues and his members
just like we saw when when Jeff Sessions
was under attack to rally behind him
just shows how far and how exhausted
Republican legislators are getting with
this back and forth and really no agenda
moving forward all right well so let's
get into that a little more how is the
president's relationship with Congress
at this point well I think they're one
person made it a very pointed remark a
colleague who's been there for about 25
years said the president couldn't
deliver a pizza right now
it they're so extremely frustrated to
build an allegiance in a coalition to
move massive reform tax reform health
care reform they have to really take a
lot of political capital a lot of shots
and if you look at the house the fact
that they felt they walked out on a limb
for a piece of legislation that the
president ultimately called mean you're
looking at a lot of House members who
seek it who see the attack ads coming
next fall of them taking a vote on
something that's undermining medic yeah
Medicare Medicaid and seniors it's not
anywhere they want to be and that's the
type of political price they don't want
to take again but it's interesting when
you look at the president he doesn't
seem to want to take direction from
others so he continues his push for
health care regardless and that's true
and that has so much more to do with the
president style he's someone who never
really had a board of directors somebody
to manage over him his style is to
really make the shots and decisions and
let them figure it out if he doesn't
like it he has these you know these
vicious attacks and he moves on I call
it like a tropical storm it's a lot of
gale force winds debris going everywhere
until he finds its next target the
problem is there's a long memory in
Washington it's not the way the game is
played and the term that they use most
often is they're getting exhausted they
don't want to see this pattern continue
well it's interesting because the
president doesn't want to seem to leave
health care reform behind at least even
for the moment but he kind of keeps
putting it back in Congress's court
as if he isn't willing to take
responsibility for it right that's true
and so we said we know what the
sentiment is on the house side on the
Senate side when they were trying to
move through whether it was the skinny
reform which had you know a lot of the
fewer measures he still called them a
bunch of losers when they were not able
to get that piece done I just see what
he's Macaulay McConnell know exactly
Kalima Connor we know what I think we
know so far the pattern in the last six
months is that this too shall pass but
the memory issue the the fact that these
members feel they're going to take the
political heat for measures that the
president is not willing to defend
himself and if you look at the base of
support his base does not have long
coattails they're basically every man
for themselves a man and woman for
themselves and with respect to that
that's not a cohesive Republican
conference and it's not something that's
gonna make this passage any easier to
the to the Russian investigation now we
heard this week suddenly from the
president support of Robert Muller which
is a very different story what can we
make of that I think overall folks are
feeling that this is this should have
been the tone from the beginning that it
should have been let the investigation
we air out give it its due time and
process we have faith that that there
will be no wrongdoing here and I think
as the pressure is heating up and you
have the new chief of staff
it's a very astute politically smart
move especially as things get more
precarious in Washington impact from
general Kelly they're very much though
Leslie Sanchez thanks for being with us
this morning